N
CRISIS.
IT IS ESTIMATED THAT MORE THAN
3.7 MILLION PEOPLE HAVE FLED TO
NEIGHBORING COUNTRIES, MORE THAN
2 MILLION HAVE GONE TO POLT
POLAND.
AND WITH ME NOW IS SEAN PENN,
COMPANY FOUNDER OF A CRISIS
RESPONSE ORGANIZATION.
YOU ARE DOING AMAZING WORK.
TELL US WHAT YOU ARE SEEING ON
THE GROUND THERE IN WARSAW.
AND WHAT STANDS OUT TO YOU AFTER
SPENDING SO MUCH TIME IN THAT
REGION?
>> WELL, I GUESS A GREAT
OVERSIMPLIFICATION.
YOU HAVE TWO IMMEDIATE CRISES.
ONE IS THE REFUGEE CRISES OF
THOSE COMING INTO POLAND AND
OTHER BORDER NATIONS.
AND THEN THIS HORRIFYING THING
THAT IS GOING ON IN UKRAINE.
AND I GUESS JUST AS MORE
IMPORTANTLY PERHAPS IS THE
EXTRAORDINARY COURAGE AND
UNIFICATION OF UKRAINE.
>> AND WE WANT TO PUT UP SOME
INFORMATION ON THE SCREEN FOR
PEOPLE IF THEY WANT TO DONATE,
THEY CAN TEXT OR GO ONLINE TO
CORE RESPONSE.ORG.
WHAT HAS YOUR RESPONSE EFFORT
BEEN LIKE AND WHAT STANDS OUT TO
YOU WHEN YOU ARE OVER THERE
DOING THIS KIND OF WORK?
>> WELL, BECAUSE I'M IN POLAND,
I SHOULD SAY THAT ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT STANDS OUT HERE IS
THE EXTRAORDINARY HEART THAT THE
POLISH PEOPLE AND GOVERNMENT ARE
SHOWING TO THESE PEOPLE THAT
HAVE BEEN PUT IN THIS TRAGIC
POSITION OF MOSTLY WOMEN AND
THEIR CHILDREN.
AND OF COURSE ALL OF US ARE
TRYING TO PARTNER WITH LOCAL
ORGANIZATIONS, UNDERSTAND THE
NEEDS HERE AND SCALE UP OUR
SUPPORT WITH AN INTENSITY.
>> AND THE STORIES JUST BREAK
YOUR HEART.
YOU KNOW, I WONDER WHAT IT FEELS
LIKE TO YOU PERSONALLY, SEAN, TO
LIVE THROUGH THIS.
THE U.S. IS SET TO TAKE IN
100,000 REFUGEES FROM UKRAINE.
A LARGE NUMBER, BUT THIS
HORRIFIC SITUATION IS CAUSING
MILLIONS TO BE DISPLACED FROM
THEIR HOMES.
IS 100,000 PEOPLE ENOUGH GIVEN
WHAT YOU'VE EXPERIENCED AND WHAT
YOU HAVE COME ACROSS?
>> I WON'T DAZZLE ANYONE WITH MY
OVERALL POLICY SENSE OF THIS,
BUT I DO BELIEVE THAT IT MAKES
SENSE THAT WHATEVER COUNTRIES IN
THE SHORT TERM AND THE LONG TERM
ARE TAKING ON THE LION'S SHARE
OF THE BURDEN, THEY AND THEIR
MUNICIPALITIES NEED
INTERNATIONAL SUPPORT.
>> AND I HAVE TO ASK YOU ABOUT
THIS, BECAUSE YOU MET WITH
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY RIGHT WHEN
THE WAR BEGAN.
HE HAS BECOME A HERO TO PEOPLE
AROUND THE WORLD FOR THE WAY HE
HAS LED HIS PEOPLE DO YOU
REMEMBER COURAGEOUSLY AND
STANDING UP TO THE INVASION.
DID YOU GET THAT SENSE OF WHAT
HE WAS MADE OF WHEN YOU WERE
TALKING TO HIM AT THE TIME?
WHAT HAS BEEN YOUR IMPRESSION?
THIS IS A GUY WHO SAID I DON'T
NEED A RIDE OUT OF TOWN, I NEED
AMMUNITION.
>> YES, YOU KNOW, I HAD MET WITH
THE PRESIDENT THE DAY BEFORE
INITIALLY THE DAY BEFORE THE
INVASION.
AND MET WITH HIM AGAIN DURING
THE INVASION.
WHAT I WOULD SAY IS I CAN'T
IMAGINE ANY HUMAN BEING WOULD
HAVE FULLY KNOWN THAT THEY WERE
BORN FOR THIS MOMENT UNTIL THIS
MOMENT WOULD HAVE HAPPENED.
SO I WOULD SAY CERTAINLY ON
THURSDAY I WAS WITH AS MOVING,
AS COURAGEOUS, AS EXTRAORDINARY
A PERSON AND FACE OF HIS
EXTRAORDINARY COUNTRY AND PEOPLE
AS I WOULD EXPECT I EVER WILL
WITNESS AND CERTAINLY THAT I
EVER HAVE.
INCREDIBLY MOVING PERIOD OF
TIME.
>> AND HAVE YOU HAD A CHANCE TO
SPEAK WITH HIM SINCE YOUR MEET
SOMETHING.
>> YES.
>> AND HOW DID THAT GO?
HOW WAS THAT?
>> YOU KNOW, ALL I'LL SAY --
I'LL JUST FOR THE MOMENT ECHO
THAT ASPECT OF IT, THAT IT
CONTINUES AND YOU KNOW, I
DON'T -- I DON'T KNOW THE
CONSENSUS, THE DOCUMENTARY TEAM
I'M WITH, IF I HAD SOMETHING
THAT I THOUGHT WAS MORE VALUABLE
TO TELL YOU, YOU KNOW, FOR THE
GREATER PROBLEM RIGHT NOW, I
WOULD.
BUT RIGHT NOW, I'M GOING TO KIND
OF REFRAIN.
>> I TOTALLY UNDERSTAND.
AND AS YOU KNOW, THE AS CORES
ARE TOMORROW NIGHT.
DO YOU WANT TO SEE PRESIDENT
ZELENSKYY SPEAK AT THE OSCARS
VIA SOME SORT OF VIDEO LINK?
AND HOW DO YOU THINK THE
CEREMONY HOW THE EVENT SHOULD
RECOGNIZE WHAT IS HAPPENING IN
UKRAINE?
WHAT WOULD YOU SAY I GUESS IF
YOU WERE THERE UP ON STAGE?
>> I'M GLAD THAT YOU ASKED THAT
QUESTION BECAUSE, YOU KNOW,
THERE ARE THOSE, AND I THINK IT
SOMETIMES HAS VALIDITY WHO WOULD
SAY THAT POLITICS ARE FOR
ANOTHER PLACE, ENTERTAINMENT IS
FOR THE ANOTHER.
I BELIEVE THAT ANYONE AS AN
AUDIENCE THAT UNDERSTANDS WHAT
THAT EXPRESSION IS, THAT TO
REDISTRICT TO JUST FILM IS TO
SAY THAT IT CAN'T BE ON
TELEVISION, IT CAN'T BE ON THE
STAGE, TO RESTRICT TO ANY OF
THOSE IS TO SAY THAT IT CAN'T BE
EMBODIED WITHIN A HUMAN BEING,
THAT KIND OF NATURE OF POETIC
COURAGE AND EXPRESSION THAT FILM
ASPIRES AT ITS BEST TO BE, THERE
IS NOTHING GREATER THAT THE
ACADEMY AWARDS COULD DO THAT BE
TO GIVE HIM THAT OPPORTUNITY TO
TALK TO ALL OF US.
AND THIS IS A MAN WHO HAS HIS
OWN SUCCESSFUL CAREER IN THAT.
AND IT IS MY UNDERSTANDING THAT
IT HAS DECIDED NOT DO IT.
IF THE ACADEMY HAS ELECTED PRES
DECIDED NOT TO PRESENT IN
SUPPORT OF THOSE THAT ARE TRYING
TO PROTECT THE UKRAINIAN, I
THINK EVERY ONE OF THOSE PEOPLE
AND EVERY BIT OF THAT DECISION
WILL HAVE BEEN THE MOST OBSCENE
MOMENT IN ALLOF HOLLYWOOD
HISTORY.
AND I HOPE IT IS NOT WHAT IS
HAPPENING.
IF IT TURNS OUT TO BE WHAT IS
HAPPENING, I WOULD ENCOURAGE
EVERYONE INVOLVED TO KNOW THAT
EVEN THOUGH IT MAY BE THEIR
MOMENT TO CELEBRATE, IT IS MORE
IMPORTANTLY THEIR MOMENT TO
SHINE AND TO PROTEST AND TO
BOYCOTT THAT ACADEMY AWARDS.
AND I MYSELF, IF IT COMES BACK
TO IT, WHEN I RETURN, I WILL
SMELT MINE IN PUBLIC.
I PRAY THAT IS NOT WHAT
HAPPENED.
I PRAY THAT THERE HAVE NOT BEEN
ARROGANT PEOPLE WHO CONSIDER
THEMSELVES REPRESENTATIVES OF
THE GREATER GOOD IN MY INDUSTRY.
THAT HAVE NOT DECIDED TO CHECK
IN WITH LEADERSHIP IN UKRAINE.
SO I'M JUST GOING TO HOPE THAT
THAT IS NOT WHAT HAS HAPPENED
AND I HOPE THAT EVERYBODY WALKS
OUT IF IT IS.
>> I HOPE THAT YOU ARE RIGHT AND
WE'LL CERTAINLY CHECK INTO THAT
AS WELL.
BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO
REPORT ON THAT OR INDEPENDENTLY
CONFIRM THAT.
BUT LET ME ASK YOU FINALLY, IS
THERE ANY WAY TO PUT INTO WORDS
WHAT YOU ARE SEEING, THE LEVEL
OF DEVASTATION THAT YOU ARE
SEEING?
AND WHAT VLADIMIR PUTIN HAS
DONE.
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, YOUR VIEWING
AUDIENCE HAS PROBABLY SEEN MORE
THAN I'VE SEEN OF COURSE, YOU
KNOW, IT IS SOMETIMES LESS IN
YOUR FACE FROM THE STREET
CORNER.
BUT WHAT I CAN SAY IS ON AN
EMOTIONAL LEVEL.
I'VE NEVER BEEN IN A POSITION OF
WHAT THE INVESTMENT THAT
CONFLICT JOURNALISTS MAKE WHERE
THEY SPEND EXTENDED PERIODS OF
TIME IN EXTREMELY SKETCHY
CIRCUMSTANCES.
CERTAINLY I'VE NEVER BEEN A
SOLDIER AND I'VE NEVER BEEN A --
BEEN WITHOUT A CHOICE TO LEAVE A
COUNTRY THAT IS UNDER THAT KIND
OF PRESSURE.
THAT SAID, YOU KNOW, I HAVE BEEN
IN SOME SITUATIONS THAT COULD BE
CONSIDERED SKETCHY FOR SHORT
PERIODS OF TIME.
AND I'VE UNDERSTOOD WHAT IT IS
TO HAVE AN ANXIETY, TO HAVE A
FEAR.
AND IN THIS CASE, ON THE DAY OF
THE INVASION, MY EMOTIONAL
BANDWIDTH WAS COMPLETELY TAKEN
UP WITH A HEARTBREAK THAT WAS
CERTAINLY IMMEDIATE AS IT
RELATED TO THE UKRAINIAN PEOPLE.
BUT IT VERY QUICKLY EXPANDED MY
OWN CHILDREN, TO EVERYBODY THAT
BELIEVES IN DREAMING AROUND THE
WORLD, IT WAS -- IT IS TRULY
HEARTBREAKING.
SO HEARTBREAKING THERE WOULDN'T
BE TIME FOR OTHER THOUGHTS.
THAT IS WHAT I'M FEELING FROM
WHAT I'M SEEING.
SO I HOPE THAT THERE IS A GREAT
WAY TO BE ABLE TO ARTICULATE FOR
ALL OF US TO BE ABLE TO
ARTICULATE TO EVERYONE AROUND
THE WORLD THAT THIS CAN BE THE
END OF DREAMING FOR OUR
CHILDREN, WHAT THIS DOES TO
POTENTIAL FOR ANY RELATIVE
NOTION OF DEMOCRACY.
UKRAINE WILL WIN THIS FIGHT.
NO QUESTION IN MY MIND.
AND THE QUESTION WILL BE WHERE
WILL WE BE WHEN THEY DID.
>> SEAN PENN, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
THANKS FOR WHAT YOU DO, THANKS
FOR JOINING US.
GET HOME SAFE, WE APPRECIATE IT.
>> THANKS VERY MUCH, JIM.
>>> AND IF YOU WANT TO DONATE TO
CORE, AS WE WERE TALKING ABOUT,
TEXT CORE TO 24365